hi everyone I'm David Griffin and I'm
Michael Medina we're here to talk to you
about the walking dead different walking
dead the video Telltale's amazing video
game The Walking Dead this is season 2
episode 2 a house divided Dennis and I
especially our last review last review
of The Walking Dead's pretty harsh said
you know this is one of the worst
episodes we've seen you know a lot of
just it's a lot of teetering a lot of
you know stretching out that story in
The Walking Dead television show but you
know what this is not an area talk about
television so we're gonna talk about the
video game little about Clementine one
of my favorite video game characters in
recent memory and Michael's going to
join me this time to talk about it so
let's let's just kind of go right into
it what are you thinking about season
two so far of the walking dead all right
well first of all yeah you know we read
the books you read the show and we play
the game and it's obviously not fair to
compare the game to either one of those
because it's an entire world yeah and um
that being said though I've gotta say
that the story that I'm that's being
told right now in this video game is far
superior than what I read in books right
and especially on the show and that's
not I'm not hating on either one of
those I just feel like the story is a
lot stronger I care more about these
characters i mean this a little like
nine year old girl or tank look at older
maybe general oh yes they're around
their love me she's just a fantastic
writer like you really see like she's
the kind of character again it's not
fair to compare but you kind of see that
with carl and the books like i'm kind of
growing up you don't really get a sense
of that in the show right as much as you
do like in the books and Clementine I
think is a perfect example of that you
see how you know when you first meet her
she's this little you know girl she's
scared freshers know what's going on it
but now you see her especially in this
episode he's bad he's bad yeah like
she's a seasoned vet so for those of you
are familiar with the walking dead again
we're I won't we won't go to the very
end of this episode so I know it just
came out yesterday so I'm not gonna
spoil too much for you but we'll get
into some season one spoiler should we
haven't played season one maybe you know
stop right now and then come back after
you play season 1 season 2 dou
Clementine would say to say is on her
own she you know had some companions the
beginning of season two but got
separated for various reasons and now
she's
she's kind of found this new family who
didn't trust her at first what some
crazy scenes you know with her locked in
a shed in the previous episode not it
still no I want to this like this some
of the lines you can play pick for
Clementine to say are awesome like last
episode there was one where the this
pregnant lady who I just can't what's
her name again i was back up Rebecca who
I did I just can't stand even though she
tries to apologize in this episode I
just can't stand it and like there's a
scene you can actually make Clementine
say you should talk nicer to me I'm just
like yeah girl a teardown I love
Clementine she's just so good she really
is and again like you and sorry I
compared Beth to Clementine a lot of
people correction being said Beth the
actors actually 28 years old way off on
that that you like 16 so Clementine is
much younger I kind of like the
relationship between Daryl and best me
that can be like Clementine but I was
like oh wait she's 28 so that's not good
but anyway but yes yeah especially like
it's going back to San wondering stuff
like you really feel for her because you
know that you know she her parents in
written the beginning I missing and she
comes across the league who comes her
dad right yeah and you could see the
relationship developing between the two
and stuff and you really feel bad for
her when spoiler alert you know her
parents are dead they're zombies yeah
you know and then you just kind of see
the struggle that she goes through I'm
like you know that initial meeting with
me to ultimately season two yeah right
now and you really feel bad for because
she really is this little girl that's
scared shes lonely she comes across the
sky Lee who she really cares for and
develops me was like her dad cuz it
season one you control Lee so it's a
much different perspective we sure Lee
talking to Clementine all the time
you're like wait what do I teach this
girl like do I give her a pot when you
have choices I give a positive outlook
on life in the world do I tell her how
it really is like how she'll be able to
survive it's kind of cool because now
like playing as Clementine you're kind
of like taking all that and kind of
actually putting it to use now yeah you
know and she's just a really strong
character for such young is great uses
such a badass I mean let's talk about
this episode specifically so in this
episode last episode we were talking
about ask me Dave did you like there's a
choice you have you can save Pete or his
son yeah you have that you have the
option of doing that and then so
Clementine is with
depend on who you save I guess I've only
done it one way for me i save p so you
with Pete in the back of the Jeep say
yeah okay grocery with feet the back of
a truck and you're surrounded by zombies
you have to get back to the you know I
guess her new family you do and then
things happen and you're forced to you
know go out in search of a new locale
you have to find a new place to stay
there's people hunting you possibly new
governor esque like character carver
this guy named yet bill or William
Carver showed up and he's kind of a
governor creepy i don't know how creepy
is but we do see he seems pretty creepy
seems like you know there's some stuff
that happens a good new character though
i think there's definitely a nice little
reveal later on I don't ruin it it's
it's cool you know it kind of helps to
tie things together a little bit but
yeah it gets really exciting at the end
and it definitely leaves with a
cliffhanger as it should only at us so
to write you know but all in all I
thought it was a strong episode of
episode one was a great way to kick off
this season in this episode just kind of
continues that right and it's always an
interesting game to review because we're
talking about we're sharing our
experiences but the same time it's like
your experience may be different you may
be saved somebody else in a previous
episode or you told somebody else I mean
like mass effect this game does remember
your decisions your decisions do matter
so anything there's a lot of there's a
lot of again a lot of moral ambiguity
there's a great scene probably the best
scene one of the best things besides a
very end on the the bridge great action
sequence with you know basically
Clementine having to you know fend for
herself and actually you know helped
save wonderful friends help save Luke I
mean it was a great scene on the bridge
just great action in this and again it's
it's not fair to compare the price oh
but it's it's a totally different style
of storytelling but I really feel like
immersed in this particular world nerd
and I did in the comic books not grandma
the books have been around for like ten
yeah I mean why can i have been reading
over a hundred issues of the series so
after a while it's a good i like the
comics but you can't get burned out
after a hundred issues of reading
absolutely absolutely and the show
whether you love it right very little
like this right you know exactly and so
far granted an aren't nearly as many
episodes of the game so I mean for I
don't have no idea
how long tail tail plans on putting this
game out right know like how many
seasons are we getting but right now so
far they're on the right track right so
again you know you might hear Jess and I
harp on walking dead from now from you
know time to time and if you're looking
for a new avenue you don't really want
to start reading a hundred issues of The
Walking Dead pick up Telltale's video
game it's not super expensive I know on
xbox and PS you think they sell what for
like 15 bucks 16 bucks for the whole
four or five episodes I think on Steam
it's like 20 22 dollars like or just
pick up one episode 45 bucks like give
it a shot you're just like a casual
gamer right it's really easy to pick up
the control you players like it's like
guys or girls whoever if let's say the
girls a game where the guy's a game
where you can play with your boyfriend
or girlfriend and you mean it's it's
easy for anybody and the stories so good
it's we're just gonna suck you in right
it's like watching it's like having just
more walking dead but in my opinion
better right now in the TV show that's
just me at least like a walking I do
like something about the locker so so
that's what we thought of APIs owed to
season two house divided you know
clementines just doing what she does is
being a badass one of the best you know
female characters I'll i right now in
video games so many good people carriers
video games right now you know of course
as always you can combine this think
you're calm you wanna come chat with us
you know Michael or myself or Dennis
talk to us about walking dead the video
games on Twitter we rat fink hero I'm at
Griffin de and I'm at mr. Michael Alexis
Joseph eyes on this YouTube page it's a
think you're a pro give us a like you
know make sure you subscribe for the
work you also going to find us on
Facebook and that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans you know just be sure
again just just like I said spread the
word social media you know just get us
out there let us know you think and yeah
we'll see you soon
you